it is now my pleasure to introduce our
keynote speaker Jeffrey house and bold
as the visionary CEO of Shutterfly Jeff
house and bold has created exciting
synergies between the very newest of new
media and our most ancient human desires
to connect with one another his company
has made it easy and fun for families
and friends neighbors classmates and
communities all over the world to share
achievements important moments and
occasions occasions like commencements 4
for example but Jeff is also created in
Shutterfly an unusually effective
organization that's widely respected for
its ability to support and sustain
innovation and creativity among its
employees Shutterfly has made just about
every list of the best places to work in
America that success can be attributed
to the intentional leadership tone that
Jeff sets right from the top on a
personal note Jeff came to Carnegie
Mellon University as an undergraduate
student the very first in his family to
go to university and while he is he was
here he worked on seven different jobs
he not only aced his subjects got
through straight A's in his first year
but also received a number of
scholarships that enabled him to go on
to master's degree and took to his
subsequent successful career as somebody
who whose personal life journey has
mirrored that of Jeff's it's my great
pleasure to admire him to look up to him
and to see what he has accomplished it's
my great pleasure now to introduce our
alumnus and university trustee Jeffrey
house involved
I wanted to show Brian old guys do
selfies too
thank you dr. Suresh for your very kind
introduction it's great to be back at my
alma mater and in Pittsburgh one of the
best cities in the entire country and
I'm glad I'm wearing this very
unconformity it's hiding my stomach from
the Primanti Brothers sandwich in the O
Fry's last night but first I'd like to
welcome the president dean's
distinguished faculty staff fellow
trustees supportive friends and family
proud parents but most importantly the
graduating class of 2014 you all deserve
that applause for making it through the
CMU gauntlet I was flattered and humbled
when dr. Suresh tasked me to be your
commencement speaker today but frankly I
was a little worried and stressed I
wonder why he asked me to speak today
especially since those that have come
before me included vice presidents of
the United States famous actors and
directors inspiring professors close to
their last lectures and even people who
had to cut off the hand to survive
seriously following Aaron is a tough act
but I began obsessing about what wisdom
could I impart on a group of such smart
and talented young women and men I went
through ten drafts I started over three
times and then I did what I did so many
times during my tenure at Carnegie
Mellon I took a shot of 24 hour energy
and pulled an all-nighter
in preparation I asked some of your
classmates about what you wanted to hear
today for me and through that process I
realized you didn't want the magic
answer not a single piece of advice on
how to tackle the world post CMU you
simply wanted to hear a few words of
wisdom about how to succeed in your
career and some thoughts about life in
general so as a CMU alumnus CEO and
father of three boys I'm going to share
a little bit about my life story and a
few thoughts as you transition to the
next phase of your life and hopefully
you'll take away a few nuggets of advice
in between texting your classmates
launching tinder to find a girlfriend in
the city you're moving to posting a
selfie on Instagram or snapchat with
that cute guy you met at club hunt this
is the second Carnegie Mellon
commencement I've attended in my
lifetime and both were great honors and
represented a personal triumph for
myself however this time I'm not hung
over and I didn't need to borrow
someone's tie I grew up in a poor family
in Brooklyn New York where we relied on
welfare go Brooklyn and food stamps for
survival my dad had a seventh grade
education and was functionally
illiterate it wasn't a given that I
would attend college based upon my
upbringing and lagged lack of supportive
role models in my life in fact even
those whose job it was to inspire and to
encourage tried to dissuade me from
attending college in my junior year of
high school I asked my guidance
counselor what school should I apply to
and he said you were good at woodshop
maybe you should be a construction
worker and I said a little angered and
frustrated I want to go to college and
he said middlesex Community College has
a good carpentry program and you'd be
lucky to get admitted
now fully outraged and determined I said
I wanted to go to a four-year college
and so he said if you
want to piss away $35 applying to
Rutgers that's your own choice so just
going to college would have been a
victory but my perseverance desire to
change my lot in the life a bit of luck
and of course the desire to impress my
high school girlfriend the salutatorian
led me to Carnegie Mellon I definitely
remember that day as I was embarking
upon a journey down the Turnpike from
New Jersey to Pittsburgh my mom with
tears in her eyes as she gave me a chock
full of nuts coffee can full of change
with $386 and 21 cents in it and that
was my entire college fund but I fought
my way into CMU and after four years of
all-nighters seven different work-study
jobs including working at entropy the
children's school campus security and
being a desk attendant at what is now
known as shade honor having dumpster
dive for pizza more times than I care to
admit sleeping in front of the fence
participating in carnival trying to beat
SDC and fringe at buggy graduating is an
ACS Presidential Scholar with double
majors and economics and business I can
confidently say I am glad I didn't
listen to my guidance counselor or any
of the naysayers in my life
so this is one of my key messages for
you today that you will hear a lot of
knows in your life how will you overcome
obstacles
how will you turn negativity into
motivation what is the strength of your
will and character when I was growing up
too many people told me I was not good
enough in some way I was too short from
the wrong side of the tracks I practiced
the wrong religion I wasn't handsome
enough nor smart enough to succeed
fortunately from my early high school
days and throughout my life I decided
not to believe the detractors in fact
they all just simply to got me more mad
and more determined to show them that
David could be Goliath but I'm not
unique and alone in this manner many
famous and successful people were told
no they failed or they were born into
unfortunate circumstances but that
didn't let them define who they were
they continued and they persevered and
ultimately they succeeded by the will
and character that they had for example
Bill Gates 1st company was a failure
Stephen King's first book I turned down
30 times Jay Z couldn't get signed to a
record label
vengo only sold one painting in his
lifetime Howard Schultz was told that
his idea for selling coffee was stupid
and Steven Spielberg got rejected by USC
twice and even Thomas Edison failed more
than 1000 times before he discovered the
light bulb my hope is that you all find
your inner courage to tell the naysayers
no and go out and prove them wrong make
sure as you obtain positions of
authority and leadership that you
encourage those around you to be the
best that they can be as I was
reflecting upon my time at CMU and
preparation
for today I was struck by how so much
has changed since I sat in your seats in
May of 1991 and yet how so little has
changed for example in 1991 the Cold War
came to an end the Union of Soviet
Socialist Republics dissolved into 15
sovereign countries in just a few short
months before the Berlin Wall had come
down the Gulf War and Operation Desert
Storm began which marked the beginning
of the United States military presence
in the Middle East which continues till
today we had global conflicts around the
world natural disasters and Technology
was changing the way that we worked
fought wars and communicated with one
another in addition we were in a
recession with unemployment rates
reaching 8% and yet the Dow Jones
crossed an all-time high at 3000 does
any of this sound eerily familiar to
2014 you may feel you're graduating into
a particularly uncertain time but the
world has always been a challenging
place with your diploma in hand your
intelligence and determination and the
95-thousand support of CMU alumni in
over 130 countries around the world I am
confident that you will as I did and
many since find your own path to success
remember what Joseph Campbell said
opportunities to find deeper powers
within ourselves come when life seems
the most challenging so while you may
not think the world I graduated into was
very similar
I see many many similarities as I look
at my career the biggest event in 1991
that impacted my life was this little
project by a man named Tim berners-lee
he announced the world wide web on the
alt dot hypertext News Group leading to
the very first web site thus altering my
future and all of our lives forever
today as you graduate the
world is still in conflict minorities
are still persecuted Middle Eastern
unrest remains politicians continue to
let power corrupt them and advances in
technology brings upon both positive and
negative changes so know the world will
never be perfect as it is run by
imperfect humans but don't fret you will
find your way in the world and I am
confident you will make it a better
place as of today you have a degree from
an exceptional University a gift that
you are just beginning to understand the
rest of your life you will be able to
fall back on your education allowing you
to take greater risks and to set your
sights even higher for some knowing what
life's calling is has been obvious since
they were singing coding acting or
building robots in their garage at the
age of six for others including me
finding one's passion is more of a
journey so take risks be willing to fail
experiment as you figure out what your
passion in life is and then have the
courage to pursue it in a word be bold
if you are passionate about the work it
will not be work perhaps you'll find
some comfort or insights as I share my
story about how I came to find my
passion of building businesses that use
technology to help people strengthen
their relationships I worked in banking
and consulting right after school I was
inspired by movies like Wall Street yes
the original partially because it paid
well and I felt I had to pay back my
student loans quickly and in part to
learn skills like the ability to
synthesize data to articulate a point of
view to interact with senior management
and initiate change within organizations
although I learned a lot in those fields
after six years I realized I wanted to
be part of a more entrepreneurial
environment where I could help build a
company and in some way change the world
from the time I left the relative safety
of banking and consulting I've worked at
five different companies over the past
16 years
all these experiences have had some
things in common first they were
startups when uncertain futures I was
passionate about their products and
services
I had mentors they allowed me to be
entrepreneurial and creative and have
real impact and perhaps most importantly
they all had missions that were both
aspirational and inspirational
in 1999 the internet boom was happening
and I joined Raging Bull one of the very
first finance websites as employee
number seven it was founded by three
twenty-year-old college dropouts and it
competed against much larger companies
like Yahoo The Wall Street Journal and
Reuters two years later when most
thought we would fail we beat the
incumbents and we ultimately sold the
company to Alta Vista one of the very
first search engines where it became the
general manager what I loved about Alta
Vista was that our tagline was smart is
beautiful isn't that appropriate for
Carnegie Mellon our mission was to
unlock the world's knowledge for
everyone and again I found myself as an
underdog fighting against much larger
companies like Yahoo AOL and Lykos
unfortunately the internet bubble burst
in March of 2000 Alta Vista failed to go
public and my paper millions turned into
a shattered dream during that difficult
period of time I had to layoff more than
400 of the 630 people that worked for me
including the best man in my wedding in
the guardian of my children while that
experience was painful both personally
and professionally I learned so much and
I grew as a leader a manager and a
person after picking myself back up I
realized failures like Alta Vista were
part of being entrepreneurial and taking
risks so I decided to try my luck again
and I turned down my offers from Disney
and Yahoo and instead joined a very
small internet auction company called
eBay eBay was founded by Pierre omitted
our on the belief that people are
basically good and that we could
fundamentally change the way people
exchange goods and services through the
use of technology during my four years
at eBay I held several leadership
positions that helped the company
from 1,000 people to more than 15,000
while at eBay has sharpened my business
and leadership skills learned how to
scale a fast growing organization built
the world-class team and pioneered new
marketing techniques after four exciting
years I left in 2005 to join Shutterfly
it was an ambitious step but I was
excited to bring my creativity and
business skills to a young company to
create a great place to work that was
also a high-performance company and in
some ways I relished the chance to once
again prove the naysayers wrong joining
Shutterfly was another risky bet
especially as a new dad I was leaving a
safe and well-paying job at the one of
the world's most profitable and
well-known internet companies I remember
my wife saying you are crazy but if
you're excited I already said yes so go
for it
and so my excitement exceeded my fears
and like so many times before I decided
to choose the uncertain path as it
turned out even though I was hired to
take the company public we were in such
disarray that I delayed the IPO I
subsequently hired a new management team
pivoted out focus from being a photo
finisher to a company founded on
storytelling and personal connections
and I defined a strategy that would help
us win change the culture from one being
demarcated by surviving the internet
bust to one demarcated by innovation and
customer centricity and I created a
mission and a vision that would inspire
us to achieve more collectively than any
of us individually thought we could our
vision became and still is to this day
to make the world a better place by
helping people share life's joy
Shutterfly had huge competitors like
Yahoo and Apple and Walmart in Google
and hallmark and Kodak and by all
accounts we should have been crushed but
we didn't we thrived almost 10 years
later we've grown the company from
nearly 50 million dollars to close to 1
billion dollars in annual revenue we've
captured more than 60 percent in the
market we survived the great financial
crisis and how customers today
trust us with more than 22 billion of
their precious life's memories
I'm truly lucky to be a part of a
company that brings smiles to all
customers and our employees on a daily
basis during your time at CMU you've sat
at the intersection of major
technological artistic and cultural
changes this coupled with rigorous
analytical and problem-solving skills a
tradition of innovation a
multidisciplinary and team-based
approach along with a sense of greater
good has provided the foundation for you
to truly change the world
I am confident as you look towards the
future and where and you find where your
hearts and the work that there will be
members of this graduating class making
important contributions across many
disciplines including engineering art
science humanities public policy
business and technology so whether you
are working on self generating and low
cost architectural structures building
computers that you control with your
mind creating new businesses and
nonprofits fueled by crowdfunding social
graphs mobile and Big Data devising
bionics using nanotechnology stem cells
and 3d bio printers writing the next
Academy Award winning motion picture or
inventing robots fueled by zero sized
intelligence and quantum electrodynamics
here are a few things that as CEO I
thought you might like to consider as
you venture out into the workforce find
a company where you are truly passionate
buy their products and services and
where you respect the people invest in
the future take risks be willing to
sacrifice title and sometimes
compensation in the short run for
experiences that will help you succeed
in the long run keep in mind that nobody
but you is going to manage your career
so seek out a rabbi at work it could be
your boss a CMU alum the person two
years older than you or the Chairman
find someone who really loves mentoring
and ask them for help always always act
with high integrity bring solutions not
just problems and
when you make mistakes and you will say
you're sorry work hard but more
importantly smarter than anyone else and
don't be constrained by your job
description ask for forgiveness not
permission take calculated risks be
willing to get fired or promoted don't
just exist and if you are unhappy and
after trying to improve things quit life
is too short to be unhappy your diploma
from CMU is a true differentiator in
regards to what field of endeavor you
choose I encourage you not to squander
the opportunities that will present
themselves take chances put yourself in
the position for opportunity to knock at
your door and when it knocks have the
courage to answer I mentioned that
despite my success in business the most
important things to me in my life have
been centered around my family
especially my wife Ruth and my three
boys who are here today as I said my
living room and worked on my speech I
thought about the important lessons that
I would want my three sons to hear upon
their graduation from college and with
enough donations and a math tutor
perhaps from Carnegie Mellon and I hope
some of these resonate with you
most importantly remember that the time
on earth is very short and you should
make the most of your lives
the average person lives to 88 or said
in another way they have 1056 months on
earth and for the average undergraduate
in the audience who is 21 that means you
have 804 months left so make the most of
your time treat each month is precious
and make sure you are enjoying each
month investing to make your future
months better helping someone else enjoy
their months are since all of you are
overachievers do all three
so here are a few thoughts about making
the most out of life don't just do what
is easy do what is right
choose passion and impact not just money
and devote yourselves to lifelong
learning do acts of unselfish
selfishness it'll make you feel better
be part of something bigger than
yourself find a group a club a cause or
an organization revel and belonging and
in the sense of a shared purpose fall
madly deeply in love and if you're going
to kiss kiss passionately say I love you
it's easy and it's not said enough make
friends with those who will make you
laugh and love you for who you are and
not what you do and lastly keep in mind
one of my favorite philosophers said his
name is Mike Tyson everyone has a plan
to they get punched in the mouth so when
you get knocked down think about what
you learned think about what you can do
different or better get your ass off the
ground and get back in the ring so as I
wrap up together our time together today
remember dream big set ambitious goals
find your passion and take risks in life
go make the most of your remaining 804
months make a few lifelong friends fall
in love enjoy the ride and follow Andrew
Carnegie's advice when he said there is
little success where there is little
laughter and finally don't let the
naysayers discourage you take their
negativity and turn it into your own
personal determination and remember
David beat Goliath thank you for the
opportunities to speak today
congratulations on all of your
achievements so far I'm confident that
your CMU diploma and the skills you've
learned at this great institution will
help you navigate the world as you find
your passion and achieve great things in
work in life congratulations class of
you